the agenda is adopted
participate in this meeting
for security
it is so decided
agenda
[Music]
mr
president madam under secretary general
distinguished ambassador ladies and
gentlemen
let me
start by stressing how much i value the
continued dialogue between the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe
and the united nations
we always see
in line with
chapter 8
of the u.n
charter stands ready to continue its
cooperation and coordination
with the united nations
our organizations
share the same goal
of strengthening international
peace security and promoting respect for
human rights
fundamental freedoms and the universal
rules
based
order
such a close cooperation
is even more needed today
when the basic principles of the u.n
charter
and international law are being
flagrantly violated
in the very heart of europe
i address you today with a sense of
urgency and moral imperative
to make every
possible effort to stop the military
aggression of the russian federation
against ukraine
the oec
was designed as a platform to diffuse
tensions
facilitate dialogue
reduce the risk of military escalation
and prevent conflicts
since the very beginning of a polish
chairmanship my goal has been to seek
compromise and facilitate dialogue
between parties
of conflict
we took over our role in the context of
growing tensions stemming from moscow's
union unilateral demands of security
guarantees
the basic premise of his demands
was fundamentally flawed
the transatlantic community is neither
enemy
nor threat to russia
or
its people
on the contrary
the west has always sought to establish
an effective framework of cooperation
with moscow
despite our reservations we offered
russia a forum to discuss within the oec
all its positive concerns related to
european security
we are
we were ready to consider in good faith
new avenues of cooperation on one
condition
that they would contribute to stability
and security in the oec area
this initiative
complemented the bilateral track of the
u.s russia dialogue
and the discussions in the nato-russia
council
russia
had a full spectrum of options to engage
peacefully and diplomatically to address
its concerns
but russia was just buying time
it its continued military built up
on ukraine borders can serious doubts
about moscow's real intentions
in the morning of february
the 24th
the worst case scenario
became
reality
the unprovoked
unjustified and pre-mediated full-scale
aggression shouted our convictions that
the horror of war in europe belonged to
the past
the
perverse attempts by the russian side to
justify the military operation
against a sovereign and peaceful country
met a cruel joke out of the u.n charter
and hercing final act
this operation poorly prepared and
executed turned out to be a strategic
and tactical failure
but
instead of
preventing further unnecessary deaths in
its own ranks the kremlin changed its
tactics
the invading force started to target the
civilian population and infrastructure
in an attempt to break the spirit
of the ukrainian people
this is deplorable
and shameless
and amounts to state terrorism
schools
hospitals and kindergartens are
deliberately being targeted with
international
banned weapons
the reports of women and children killed
and wounded
are devastating
it is
if geneva conventions
and humanitarian law
never existed
make no mistake about it the
international community has instruments
and means to hold responsive those who
commit
and are complicit in war crimes
i have been recently
accused
by the russian officials of the lack of
impartiality in conducting my job as the
ovc
chairman in office
i have only one response to this kind of
allegations
the impartiality
ends where
blatant violence violation of
international
humanitarian law starts
in moments like v's
it is our moral obligation to maintain
decency
and integrity
the perpetrators will be judged
by their deeds
but we will be judged by the way
we respond
to these horrors
we cannot
stay indifferent
let me quote elie wiesel
who had return of the new millennium
famously
said
indifference
is always
the friend of the enemy
for
it benefits the aggressor
never his victim
whose pain is magnified when he or she
feels forgotten
the political prisoner in his cell
the hungry children the homeless refugee
not to respond to replied
not to relieve their solitude by
offering them a spark of hope
is to exile them from human memory
and in defying their humanity
we
betray
our own
it is russia
supported by the russian regime
that has decided to act outside the
parameters and boundaries
of international law and unfortunately
it is the russian leadership
that provokes
the growing isolation of the country
and the russian people
from the world
the international community
has rightly condemned russia's invasion
and called on moscow to withdraw its
forces from ukraine
the world
is not looking away
it is hard to ignore
141 countries assembled in the u.n
general assembly asking mr putin
to stop this war
we are also sending a strong signal to
minsk not to participate in this cruel
endeavor
the war
is against the interests of the russian
and belarusian people and leads only to
isolation
we expect the russian side to honor
its international obligations
and commitments
sustainable political solution
must fully respect sovereignty
territorial integrity and independence
of ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
the door
to diplomacy is still open
and i call on russia to engage in a
meaningful and substantial dialogue
to seek a peaceful solution to the
current crisis
mr president
distinguished ambassadors
russia's
aggression
threatens
the very existence
of oec
it is
well it's
non-compliance we've always see
principles and commitments poses
questions not only about the future of
the organization
but also about stability
of a rules
based order
how effective
can we be if one of the major
stakeholders
has repeatedly justified the use of
force
to win territorial
and political concessions
this logic
fundamentally clashes with the norms
that we all have agreed
to abide by
the oece
is not a treaty-based international
organization but it is very much
embedded
in the context of multilateral diplomacy
for almost 50 years
it has been an instrument to advance
peaceful cooperation based on
comprehensive security
given the inclusive character of the
organization i still believe
that it is the right platform for
dialogue
and peaceful resolution
of conflicts
the oec has become more than just a talk
shop between east
and west
it has a solid work record
and a multi-layer outreach
its presence
plays a stabilizing role in diverse
regions such as western
the western balkans and central asia
in my capacity as we always see sure i
will pay visits to moldova
south carol kazoos as well as the
western balkans and central asia
to prove
all we see is engagement
with participating states
this
legacy is still relevant
in today's world
however
the future of the organization depends
on how effectively we will be able to
revive cooperation among all
all participating states
the question is
how to reach consensus around the main
priorities
and how to create a proper modus
operandi to fulfill the oec mandate
i have to admit
that
this non-compliance
with oec's principles is forcing us to
put
on hold or delay
some of the issues important for the
daily operation
of the organization
will we be able to achieve progress on
regional and protracted conflicts when
trans has been shattered
i very much hope so
but it will require acting in good faith
on the part of all parties
including russia
the same applies to the renewed european
security dialogue which the published
chair initiated in response to growing
tensions
supported by an overwhelming majority of
a participating states
it was meant to develop new measures of
trust
transparency and confidence
unfortunately
despite initial interest the russian
side has chosen the most destructive
path of confronting its
concerns
fears
and misgivings
the changing situation
on the ground will probably determine
the scope and character of the future
engagement
of a special monitoring mission in
ukraine
acknowledging the mission's eight years
of operation and its expertise
i will work with the oec structures and
participating states to utilize its
potential in the future
i hope
that both the mission dedicated staff as
well as the team of the oec
project coordinator in ukraine will be
able
to continue very important mission
during the polish chairmanship we will
initiate
and actively support efforts
to advance the oec's goals
we
do not
want to alter the fundamental premise of
the osce cooperation based on agreement
by all participating states however
we would like to increase the
effectiveness of the organization
provided
that there is a broader interest and
support for the majority
of stakeholders
the recent events
in ukraine have once again
shown a spotlight on the situation of
civilian population in conflict-affected
areas
we will continue
to call on all sides of military
conflicts to abide by humanitarian law
and to refrain from activities
directed against civilian population and
infrastructure
we always see stands ready
to cooperate closely
with you and humanitarian agency
agencies to facilitate and provide
the necessary assistance
this must also include creating
effective evacuation routes
for the civilian population
whenever there are reliable accounts of
humanitarian law abuse
we should be ready
to react swiftly
therefore
we welcome the decision of a permanent
council
of march referred to invoke the moscow
mechanism to create a group of
independent experts to investigate the
reported violation of humanitarian law
in the context of the hostilities in
ukraine
ladies and gentlemen
i am convinced
that we always oec needs strong
and effective leadership now
more
than
ever before
the dramatic events in ukraine have
opened our eyes to the need
for a renewed commitment to we always
see principles
and commitments
it is true that oec
may evolve as a result of a current
experience
the celebrations of the 50th anniversary
of the helsinki final act
could turn out to be
dedicated to finding a solution
for the deep crisis of multilateralism
peace and security
like
freedom and democracy cannot be taken
for granted
we have learned this lesson
the hard way
but it is also true
that those who choose to embark on a
path of military confrontation
receive
very little
in return
between war and peace
life and destruction
we should always be able to look beyond
our narrow
narcissistic
instincts
what alternative do we have
smoldering ashes of kiev harkiff
and
mariupol
and thousands of innocent lives lost
are
a spark reminder of a heavy price that
we pay for indifference
in the face of brute force
it is therefore
high time
for the international community for the
united nations as well as for the oec
to reinforce our efforts
to restore peace
and revert to our principles and values
the integrity of international law
and stability of the world order
are at stake
mindful
of immense challenges that we face
let us work together on the most
effective ways
to save lives
and prevent
future conflicts
thank you
mr president
thank you for the invitation to join his
excellency foreign minister rao to brief
the council on un-osce cooperation
the tragic conflict in ukraine which
over the weekend has further worsened
vividly illustrates the importance of
mechanisms to maintain and strengthen
european and international peace and
security
born out of the cold war
the osce has been at the center of
efforts to bring its unique membership
spanning from vancouver to vladivostok
around one overarching goal
to resolve differences peacefully
in line with chapter eight
of the united nations charter the osce
works in complement to the u.n
including to resolve conflicts in the
region
in 1993
the un and the osce established a
cooperation framework
since then our partnership has grown in
scope and substance to help address
acute crises and find solutions to
common peace and security challenges
our shared commitment to preventive
diplomacy
mediation peace building and the women
peace and security agenda was reaffirmed
through the joint declaration between
the secretary general and the
chairperson in office in 2019
the coordination and complementarity
guiding our efforts translate into
action in various ways
we work together in central asia most
recently to implement the un global
counterterrorism strategy
in the western balkans to advance
reconciliation
and in the caucasus where the un
co-chairs the geneva international
discussions on georgia
along with the osce and the eu
further the u.n has sought to complement
the osce's leading role to address
protracted conflicts
regarding nagorno-karabakh and moldova
regarding ukraine and pursuant to
security council resolution 2202
on the minsk agreements
the u.n has consistently supported the
work of the osce
especially the special monitoring
mission
and the osce led trilateral contact
group
while carrying out our humanitarian and
human rights mandates on the ground
i wish to pay tribute here
to all osce staff for their important
work accomplished under very challenging
circumstances
mr president the war in ukraine is the
most severe test the osce and related
regional frameworks have faced since
their creation
the russian invasion has shaken the
foundations
of the european security architecture to
its core
as we meet
the bloodshed continues to worsen
russian forces have now launched daily
deadly airstrikes in the west of ukraine
ukrainian cities are under unrelenting
shelling and bombardment with many
civilians killed daily
as i said three days ago in this very
chamber
the office of the high commissioner for
human rights has received credible
reports of russian forces using cluster
munitions including in populated areas
indiscriminate attacks
including those using cluster munitions
which are of a nature to strike military
objectives and civilians or civilian
objects without distinction
are prohibited under international
humanitarian law
we are deeply disturbed by reports that
ukrainian municipal officials in
russian-controlled parts of the country
have been abducted
there are also reports of civilians
including journalists being targeted
targeted
allegedly by russian forces
president
we must not allow any questioning of the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
such questioning would be inconsistent
with the united nations charter and
relevant security council and general
assembly resolutions
amid these dire conditions the united
nations continues to scale up not only
its humanitarian support to the people
of ukraine but also its engagement with
key partners like the osce
in support of an immediate ceasefire and
a lasting diplomatic solution
when the secretary general addressed
this council on the topic of conflicts
in europe in 2017
he warned that despite the achievements
of the last 70 years we should not take
peace and prosperity in europe for
granted
he cautioned that as serious conflicts
persisted in europe
new threats and risks made it even more
pressing for multilateral institutions
and regional organizations
to address dangerous challenges to the
international order
the secretary general's warnings
then were informed in large part by the
crisis in georgia in 2008 and in ukraine
in
2014. which demonstrated how real the
risks of new outbreaks of conflict were
today a devastating war is being waged
in a continent that should be equipped
to prevent such catastrophes
we are concerned at the dismantling of
long-standing confidence-building
measures arms control treaties and other
frameworks that were designed and agreed
to sustain regional security
this includes the persistent use of
regional mediation mechanisms as tools
not to solve conflicts but to manage
them
which only helps ensure that those same
conflicts continue
osce led processes supported by the
international community are now openly
questioned by parties involved in them
mr president it is more important than
ever for all parties to recommit to the
principles of the helsinki final act the
charter of paris
and other landmark agreements that form
the bedrock of european security
architecture
in this context we take good note of the
efforts by the polish chairperson in
office under minister rey's leadership
to initiate a renewed osce european
security dialogue
how the osce and other regional actors
choose to secure the future of european
security cooperation
will have an impact beyond europe
the un supports all efforts to restore
mutual trust and respect among regional
stakeholders which is essential to
preserving the continent from new
conflict and the world from further
instability
we therefore all have a stake in the
outcome
mr president for almost 50 years the
united nations and the osce have
partnered to promote european peace and
stability
the challenges we face today and those
potentially ahead demand that we work
even more closely together thank you
i thank you mr carlo for her briefing
i now give the floor
to those council members who wish to
make statements
to the representative of norway
president
let me start by warmly welcoming
chairperson in office minister rai
to the security council and thank him
for his briefing on behalf of the osce
i thank him also for his personal
initiatives to reinvigorate the osce
as a platform for dialogue on issues of
european security
thanks also to usgd kalo for her
briefing
we don't include with an inclusive
mandate and participation the oce has a
rich toolbox for increasing transparency
building trust
and reducing tensions
using the organization's full potential
to solve the crisis of today is
essential
but the necessary political will is also
required
president we commend the ioc for now
turning the focus on its work in ukraine
towards mitigating the growing
humanitarian crisis
good use should be made of the osce's
special monitoring mission to ukraine
the smms
national staff on the ground
the oec premises
its fleet of vehicles
and the smm
long experience as an intermediary
facilitating localized ceasefires
the osce can also provide valuable
competence on border management and
human trafficking
and we again reiterate our condemnation
of russia's illegal and unprovoked
military aggression against ukraine
that makes this expertise again
necessary in europe
the russian aggression is a serious
violation of international law and
ukraine sovereignty and territorial
integrity we redraft our call on the
russian federation to immediately
withdraw its forces from ukrainian
territory and seize all threats and
military actions
russia's warfare in urban unpopulated
area and the use of heavy explosive
weapons is causing terrible long-term
harm to civilians
russia must fulfill its obligation to
protect civilians including children and
children infrastructure
we are appalled by the lack of respect
for international humanitarian law and
the worsening humanitarian crisis across
ukraine
for which russia
alone bears the sole responsibility
humanitarian actors in ukraine must be
allowed to stay and deliver
in addition we are concerned about the
steadily increasing strain on
neighboring countries as people flee the
fighting
nevertheless nevertheless let me use
this opportunity to commend poland the
polish people and other oce neighbors on
their response to the humanitarian
crisis
the warm welcome and the protection you
offer all refugees is a strong symbol of
international solidarity
president while the crisis in ukraine
requires most of our attention currently
minister rau has stated that the broad
priority for their chairmanship is
contributing to finding peaceful
solutions also to regional and protected
conflicts
the osce continues to support
reconciliation and conflict prevention
efforts in other parts of the region
such as the south caucasus moldova and
western balkans and central asia
the field missions the autonomous
institution and the secretariat
are important assets unique to the osce
that we must continue to recognize and
support
both the un and the oce share a vision
our common duty is to work to
strengthen security at the regional
level to end violent conflict and ensure
that human rights democracy rule of law
and gender equality can be enjoyed by
all
in closing especially in this current
unstable european climate let me
underline norway's strong support to the
important role of the osce in promoting
stability peace and democracy for more
than a billion people
thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
her statement
i give the floor to the representative
of ghana
thank you very much mr president
i warmly welcome to the council his
excellency
mr zibig new rao the minister for
foreign affairs
of poland and chairman in office of the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe
i thank you excellency for the briefing
on the oac osce
and note that poland has assumed the
leadership of this important
organization
at a time when the security situation
and the political military environment
in europe is fast deteriorating
we therefore look forward to the oec's
continued engagement and your leadership
in helping to address the prevailing
security challenges in europe i also
thank usg rosemary dicarlo
for her briefing and welcome the
participation of the representative of
ukraine
in this meeting
mr president canada takes note of the
issues outlined by the osce chairman in
office
in particular the commitment to pay
special attention to finding peaceful
solutions to the conflicts
in the osce area
and encourages all efforts in resolving
the protracted situations in bosnia has
governor georgia kazakhstan and nagona
nagono karaba
as well as the alarming situation in
ukraine following the russian
federation's unjustified aggression
against its neighbor we also look
forward to the additional efforts that
will be made to respond effectively
to the complex challenges of increased
fragmentation
terrorism anti-semitism transporting
crimes
and violations of human rights and
freedoms that europe is present
presently grappling with
mr president against this backdrop i'd
like to make the following additional
points
first ghana welcomes the polish
commitment to uphold the concept of
comprehensive and indivisible security
based on the helsinki final act and the
charter of paris for a new europe
as well as other decisions of the osce
which also embodied the very principles
and purposes of the united nations
insurance security on the european
continent today requires of the
participating states of the osce
a renewed commitment to uphold and
respect the long-established principles
for interstate relations
the principles of sovereignty political
independence territorial integrity
non-aggression and the prohibition
of the use or threat of the use of force
remain the foundational principles
upon which national
and global aspirations for economic and
social development can be built
any attempts to redefine and renegotiate
these bulwarks of stability
will not only undermine the european
security architecture
but also the rules-based international
order and multilateralism
the osce must therefore undertake the
difficult but necessary task of
fostering police car role
and the recommitment of its member
states to the implementation of their
international obligations
towards the peace security
and stability of europe as well as its
wider membership beyond europe
persistence and confidence and security
building measures among the
participating states of the osce
will therefore have to be sustained
secondly the osce's role as an important
forum for dialogue on the security
architecture of europe
needs to be re-emphasized
we believe that the osce provides a
unique platform for open and good faith
discussions among its 57 participating
states
if the schisms that have been opened up
in the contemporary european security
are to be addressed
we therefore welcome the ongoing air
force by the oac to facilitate dialogue
between the russian federation and
ukraine as party to the trilateral
contact group responsible for the
implementation of the 2015 minsk
agreement
the osc is indispensable in finding
and implementing a comprehensive and
peaceful settlement of the conflict
which regrettably has assumed the
full-scale dimension
we know to regret in this context
that the special monitoring mission had
to suspend its reporting activities
following the evaluation of its
international staff members to
neighboring countries
and remain concerned by cascading
security humanitarian
economic and developmental impacts of
the situation in ukraine
all efforts towards the pacific
resolution of this conflict through
dialogue and diplomacy
must therefore be encouraged and
engender the full support of this
council
thirdly we welcome the osce's efforts to
enhance its cooperation with the united
nations
ghana strongly supports the
strengthening of relations between the
united nations and regional and
aboriginal organizations
in the maintenance of international
peace and security
chapter 8 of the charter of the united
nations provides that the security
council
in pursuit of this mandate can leverage
the comparative advantage of regional
bodies
to promote homegrown
and regional approaches to the
maintenance of international peace and
security
we acknowledge however the complexities
that such cooperation entails and it's
for this reason that ghana is working
within the special
committee
on the charter of the organization
to identify gaps and propose guidelines
to enhance complementarity between the
united nations and regional
organizations
finally we note the enhanced engagement
of the united nations and osce aimed at
finding lasting peace
to the prevailing conflicts and growing
threats to security in europe and beyond
we welcome the focus on human-centered
approach and in that regard
take note of the reinforcing priorities
within the economic environment
dimensions as well as the human security
dimensions i thank you very much mr
president
i give the floor to the representative
of the united kingdom
thank you mr president
and thank you chair and office foreign
minister rao for your briefing and under
secretary general de carlo
for yours
i would like first to pay tribute to the
bravery and dedication
of osce staff
and in particular to marina fanina a
ukrainian special monitoring mission
employee
who was killed in the russian shelling
of karjev on the 1st of march
while getting medicine for her family
for decades the osce has worked to bring
security to europe
and yet we meet today
in the middle of russia's unprovoked
invasion of ukraine
one osce signatory
tearing up the rulebook and pursuing war
against another
as foreign minister rao said
as if the geneva conventions and
humanitarian law never existed
president putin's war
violates fundamental principles of both
the osce and the united nations
sovereignty
environment in viability of borders
respect for territorial integrity
and the peaceful settlement of disputes
this war is a threat to us all
to the systems we have built together to
preserve
peace
it's a threat too
to the peace and security
of millions of people
in europe africa and asia
who rely on agricultural energy and
commodity supply chains
already profoundly disrupted by russia's
invasion
we recognize the extensive efforts
which foreign minister rao described
which the osce has made to try and avoid
this catastrophe
russia was offered a chance to raise any
security concerns in the osce renewed
european security dialogue
but said it was not the right time
we now know they were planning war all
along
ukraine and others invoked the osce
vienna document risk reduction mechanism
to seek transparency from russia and
belarus and to de-escalate the situation
russia refused to engage
and of course the osce has worked for
years to support implementation of the
minsk agreements
russia is accused of the gravest war
crimes
bombing schools
hospitals and homes
targeting families
as they try to run to safety
we welcome action taken under the moscow
mechanism to hold russia to account
the osce fact-finding mission must be
given full access so that evidence can
be gathered
finally mr president
i would like to stress that we continue
to support the vital role of the osce
field missions
in central asia and the western balkans
including
through its office for democratic
institutions and human rights
we strongly support
osce efforts
to facilitate a peaceful resolution
of the conflicts in georgia moldova and
nagorno-karabakh
the united kingdom remains steadfast in
our support and appreciation for the
work of the osce and for poland's
chairmanship at this critical time
i thank you mr president
yes
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for her briefing for her
statement and i give the floor to the
representative of france mr president
mr president
i would like to please
of the
osce
that meeting this ministry russian
deputy minister confirmed
to attack
the implementation of the minsk
agreement
their support to this aim every year in
february
mr president
founding
and
solutions to the crisis and challenges
[Music]
um
a victim of the russians
uh
yes
foreign
um
we're determined
that the two organizations are
developing to contribute to the
settlement of crises in europe
i thank the representative of france for
his statement i give the floor to the
representative of albania
thank you mr president
let me thank the oec chairman office
minister rao
and usg carlo for the information
provided
we welcome this timely exchange with
osce one of the world's largest regional
security organizations which brings
together 57 member participating states
across three continents bound by joint
commitments
as an important pillar of the
international rules-based order oec
plays an essential role in addressing
many of the challenges on the council's
agenda
therefore the collaboration and
partnership between the two
organizations is key and needs to be
strengthened
albania fully supports the priorities of
polish ovc chairmanship
we welcome the focus on safeguarding a
comprehensive security order by
defending the principles of the helsinki
final act
the paris charter and the charter for
european security
these principles are neither negotiable
nor subject to revision or
reinterpretation
the commitment to human rights
values of freedom and democracy as well
as the support of its institutions
should continue to be an irreplaceable
blueprint in the work of the osce
we also welcome the work of the oec and
the united nations in the framework of
women peace and security agenda and
reconciliation processes in the western
balkans
there has hardly been a more suitable
and urgent time to reaffirm these
fundamental principles which for nearly
five decades have stood as effective
mechanisms to conflict prevention and
de-escalation in europe
until the 24th of february
dear colleagues
in 2020
soon after albania assumed the oec
chairmanship in office
we were confronted with an invisible
enemy which threatened the entire world
it went by the name covet 19 pandemic
we still do not know everything about it
but we do know far too well what it did
to humanity to our way of life to our
countries and economies and in many ways
to all of us
two years later
as poland started its chairmanship the
osce area was confronted with another
threat
but this time everyone knew where it was
coming from
we were warned about what was going to
happen
and now
three weeks into this war we are left
with the uninterrupted onslaught of
breaking news
on the devastation that russia is
unleashing with rage upon ukraine and
its people
dear colleagues
for months
huge efforts were made by the
international community including by the
polish chairmanship and yourself
minister
in seeking a peaceful solution
every stone was turned every possibility
was used
the reality shows clearly now that these
efforts were doomed to fail
because the invasion was premeditated
it was a plan to be executed despite
everything
it was a war kremlin wanted
we express our gratitude to poland
slovakia hungary romania moldova the
czech republic and probably i'm
forgetting for these incredible efforts
that they are making in sheltering
thousands of civilians forced to flee
the massive bombardments and war
atrocities
dear colleagues
oec is a key player for peace and
security it is an important platform to
discuss issues related to comprehensive
security equipped with mechanisms as
well as confidence and security building
measures
it remains as relevant as it as when it
was created
it is clear that the overarching
difference between russia and the
existing european security order
based on international law and osce
principles is a structural one
while we are served here with all kinds
of fantasies that melt like snow under
the sun
the real concerns are democratic values
and principles of freedom on which the
system is based
in this respect
the oac comprehens comprehensive concept
of security connects the dots between
domestic oppression and external
aggression
democracy human rights and rule of law
are key aspects for security within
and between states
mr president we failed to prevent the
pure unprovoked and unjustified act of
aggression committed by a serial
violator of the rules and norms of the
international order
we should not fail to make the aggressor
pay for it and the crimes committed
albania supports the initiative to
invoke the oec moscow mechanism in order
to establish facts of war crimes and
crimes against humanity including due to
deliberate and indiscriminate acts
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure in ukraine
its findings together with those of the
commission of inquiry established by
human rights council
should be presented to relevant
accountability mechanisms as well as
national regional and international
courts or tribunals
the massive sanctions imposed on russia
have ripple effects for the whole world
including for our own countries and
citizens
but it is the price to pay so that
russia's actions do not go unchecked and
unpunished
we hope that the effects of these
unprecedented sanctions
will wake up the russian citizens
to see the reality through the terrible
deeds of their army not through the
distorted mirror of propaganda
to understand why the whole world calls
russia an aggressor
to feel for their neighbor that is being
savagely destroyed cities that are
becoming graveyards children that are
forcefully leaving their childhood
behind because of such insanity
the sooner this happens
the sooner this war and it and any
spillover threats will stop
let me and mr president by recalling the
754th meeting of the security council on
4 november
1956 history has recorded it as the day
when a popular revolt in hungary was
viciously crashed by soviet tanks
uninvited of course
i will quote mr sobolev
the representative of the union of
soviet socialist republics at that
meeting justifying the action and i
quote
the nagi government openly adopted a
reactionary and fascist policy aimed at
the complete liquidation of the people's
democratic regime in hungary at the at
the restoration of the old land owner
capitalist system and the establishment
of a fascist dictatorship and of course
it was about the so-called fascist 65
years ago
it is about the so-called
nazis and denasification now
the same discourse the same action with
their terrible consequences
ukraine is a critical test for european
security including osce
we must refuse a world according to
russia
we must determine the preservation and
the enforcement of the rules-based
international order
one man has started this war
one man can stop it
anytime
thank you
mr president
at the outset let me thank minister hau
for his thoughtful remarks
i also thank usgd carlo for her briefing
osce plays a crucial role in the
maintenance of peace and security in
europe
it is one of the key partners of the
united nations in dealing with the many
challenges on the security council's
agenda
however
we need to recognize that at this
crucial juncture junction
the architecture of peace and security
not only in europe but worldwide is
facing an unprecedented challenge
the conflict the conflict in ukraine
with its store of humans
with with its store of human suffering
forced displacement
humanitarian emergency
and systemic risk is an extraordinary
challenge for united nations and the occ
in their joint mission to guarantee
peace and security in europe
the cessation of hostilities
must be our most pressing objective
all parties must fully respect
international humanitarian law and adopt
measures to protect civilians
we call for continued efforts to agree
on well-planned humanitarian mechanisms
that ensure
the safe passage of civilians
furthermore we should strive for the
immediate full
safe and unhindered assets of
humanitarian personnel for a timely
delivery of assistance to those in need
moreover the war in ukraine
was momentous has momentous implications
for the international order especially
the principles enshrined in the u.n
chart
in this regard brazil calls on all
parties to strictly observe
the international law
the prohibition of the use of force the
peaceful resolution of disputes and the
principles of sovereignty territorial
integrity no intervention and the
protection of human rights
shall remain
the pillars of our collective security
system
we note that the present conflict will
also have a significant impact on
commodities and energy prices
such effects
could be further worsened by the
application of unilateral sanctions
developing countries stand to bear a
disproportionate burden of such negative
shocks
there is no alternative to diplomatic
talks
the security concerns of all parties
must be addressed by meaningful
negotiations
we renew our plea for them to engage in
dialogue with openness flexibility and a
sense of urgency to find ways for a
lasting peace in ukraine
and in the wider region
the osce
has a key role to play in supporting
international efforts to bring an end to
the current hostilities
moreover the expertise of the osce
may be that may be valuable in
monitoring a ceasefire that we hope
will encompass a comprehensive
disengagement of troops and military
equipment on the ground
besides the conflict in ukraine
we also would like to mention the
ongoing crisis in georgia as well as the
dispute between armenia and azerbaijan
over the region of nagorno-karabakh
regarding the situation in georgia we
commend the osc for its full support to
the geneva international discussions and
related incident prevention and response
mechanism formats
this dialogue
this dialogue process co-chaired by the
osce
un
and eu
is important example of
un osce cooperation in conflict
resolution
the unresolved conflict
over nagorno-karabakh
remains a challenge to international
peace and security in europe
after the armed conflict of 2020
we are still witnessing renewed
outbreaks of clashes between azeri's and
armenians
some of them result in casualties
including among civilians
last week
incidents damaged the main pipeline that
brings gas to nagorno-karabakh
such incidents further undermine the
needed trust between armenia and
azerbaijan to renew
efforts towards a lasting peace
agreement
we support the efforts undertaken by osc
in order to give impetus to this process
we would also like to express our
recognition to osce work to advance the
women peace and security agenda
important issues such as the impunity
for sexual and gender-based violence
must be tackled
in that regard we note the openness of
the oic to involve civil society
russia was brought back the russian
delegation to the parliamentary assembly
back in 2019 where your gathering now
once again showed
a poor understanding by the world of the
real threat
that putin's regime is
then europe chose the road of pacifying
the aggressor
rather than defending the demo the
values democracy the rule of law and
human rights
for the past 18 days the world finally
opened up the eyes we never closed our
eyes not for a second
18 days of this open war
thousands of deaths
the loss of almost 90 children
thousands of ukrainians
without any food any water any heat
destruction of hundreds of schools
hospitals that have been shelled
nuclear power plants on the brink of a
disaster and that's at the time when
russia
according to the convention on human
rights
and fundamental freedoms vowed that it
would
promote the right to life and defend any
person from a lawful violence dear
members of the assembly the right to
life
is one of the key fundamental rights
and today at the center of europe this
right is being violated every minute and
every second
for the leaders of the russian
federation there are no values at all
the russian armed forces behave like
terrorists them bombard schools
kindergartens hospitals they killed
to silence narratives that challenge its
propaganda
and it underscores
the importance of upholding the safety
of journalists
as they undertake their important work
excuse me
last year at this meeting
uncooperation
thank you
last year
at this meeting on cooperation
between the u.n and the oc
the united states recalled
that we had just passed the seventh
anniversary
of russia's invasion and occupation of
crimea
and the launch of its aggression
in eastern ukraine
we noted that in those seven years
the russian-fueled conflict in eastern
ukraine
had killed more than thirteen thousand
people and wounded tens of thousands
more
and we warned
that russia's aggression was far from
over
it had been less than three weeks since
russia launched a major invasion against
the rest of ukraine
during these three weeks russia
unleashed horrific devastation
against another u.n member state
resulting in the death of thousands
and the displacement of over 2.5 million
people
russia must immediately cease all
hostilities withdraw its forces from
ukraine and take the path of diplomacy
in keeping with the principles of the
u.n charter and the helsinki final act
mr president
russia's further invasion of ukraine is
an unprecedented challenge
a challenge to the post-world war ii
european security order
and cooperation
between all of us
cooperation between the un and osce now
remains as essential as ever
unfortunately
two osce participating states the
russian federation and belarus
continue to violate
the foundational principles of the u.n
charter and the helsinki final act
russia with belarus's support has shown
utter contempt for the sovereignty and
territory integrity of other states
as well as for the human rights
and fundamental freedoms of its own
people
we have seen russia try to spread
disinformation
and distract this council from its
aggression
but no amount of russian disinformation
can distract from this fact
the kremlin is waging a brutal
premeditated unprovoked war of choice
against ukraine
this is a war carried out with the
support
and the facilitation
of the lukashinka regime
russia does not want its people to learn
the appalling truth about the senseless
death and destruction it is causing in
ukraine
this is why the kremlin has forced
domestic and foreign independent media
outlets to suspend their operations in
russia or to close permanently
this is why it has blocked access to
independent news sites and social
networks
the united states reaffirms its strong
and unwavering commitment to the osce's
special monitoring mission
which has been forced to temporarily
suspend its work in ukraine
despite russia's efforts to impede its
operations
the special monitoring missions
impartial reporting
has proved invaluable to the
international community's understanding
of the security situation on the ground
we join others in expressing our
heartfelt condolences for the loss of
staff member marina finina who on march
1st was killed by russia's shelling in
kharkiv while trying to get supplies for
her family
the united states was proud to join 44
other countries in launching the osce
moscow mechanism to establish an expert
mission the mission will document human
rights violations and abuses
breaches of international humanitarian
law
and possible war crimes and crimes
against humanity committed by russia's
forces in ukraine's territory
the mission will meticulously compile
the facts and create a written report
that can be presented to relevant
accountability mechanisms
we also welcome the u n human rights
council's immediate launch of a
commission of inquiry to pursue similar
aims
the commission of inquiry and the osce
expert mission will complement one
another in bringing the truth to light
under the osce vienna document all
participating states committed to
respond in good faith
to the concerns that other states raise
regarding unusual military activities
as part of our collective efforts to
reduce the risk of miscalculation lower
tensions and build confidence
russia's blatant and unfounded dismissal
of ukraine's legitimate invocation
of the vienna document
risk reduction mechanism for unusual
military activities
illustrated once again russia's
disregard of its international
commitments
belarus's refusal to substantively
respond to the baltic states invoking
the vienna document risk reduction
mechanism
showed that lukashinka regimes disregard
as well
mr president in addition to russia's
aggression against ukraine as others
have mentioned we must also not forget
the other important priorities of the
osce
we must not forget that russia continues
to occupy
parts of georgia
it also maintains its forces in moldova
without host government consent
we welcome the continued commitment of
the osce to seek a peaceful resolution
of the conflict in georgia including by
co-chairing the geneva international
discussion
we regret that russia has not fulfilled
its obligation and its commitments under
the 2008 ceasefire agreement
including withdrawal of troops to
pre-conflict positions
the united states urges all geneva
international discussion participants to
ensure residents of conflict-affected
areas are able to visit their relatives
engage in peaceful economic activities
and to move freely without fear of
detention or arbitrary punishment
and with access to documentation that
will allow them to return to their homes
the united states remains committed
to promoting a peaceful democratic and
prosperous future for the south caucus
region
as immense group co-chair we join others
in urging armenia and azerbaijan to
continue and intensify their diplomatic
engagement
to find comprehensive solutions to all
outstanding issues related to or
resulting from the negrono-karabakh
conflict
in conclusion mr president the united
states appreciates the long-standing
partnership between the un and the osce
u.n presentations at osc permanent
council meetings and u.n participation
in annual osce events
as well as the close coordination
between osce field operations and u.n
agencies on the ground have only
strengthened this partnership
in the face of russian aggression the un
and osce must continue working together
to advance peace security development
and human rights
which will contribute to international
peace and stability thank you very
much after being hit by russian forces
schools
lie in ruins
according to the world's organization at
least 24 health facilities have suffered
attacks
hundreds of thousands of people
are without water or electricity
and with each passing hour two things
are increasingly clear
first
it kept getting worse
second
whatever the outcome
this war will have no winners
only losers
the united nations and humanitarian
partners are working to ensure safe
passage from basic areas
and to provide aid where security
permits
more than 600 000 people
have received some form of aid
as millions of people in ukraine face
hunger and dwindling supplies of water
and medicine
i'm announcing today that the united
nations will allocate a further 40
million us dollars from the central
emergency response fund
to ramp up vital assistance to reach the
most vulnerable as we wait for the
nations to come
this funding will help get critical
supplies of food water medicines and
other life-saving aid
into the country as well as provide
cash assistance to the needy
but the avenues in and out of encircled
cities are more precarious by the day
and i underscore the crucial importance
of respecting international humanitarian
law
at least 1.9 million people are
displaced inside the country
and growing numbers are escaping across
borders
i'm deeply grateful for the solidarity
of ukraine's neighbors and other host
countries who have taken in more than
2.8 million refugees in the past two
weeks
the vast majority of those making the
thresherous journey are women and
children who are increasingly vulnerable
for predators and human traffickers
war is not a tragedy it is an
opportunity
and women and children are the targets
they need safety and support
every step of the way
i will continue to highlight the
desperate plight of the people of
ukraine as i am doing again today
yet
there is another dimension of this
conflict that gets obscured
this war goes far beyond ukraine
it is also an assault on the world's
most vulnerable people and countries
while war reigns over ukraine
a sword of damocles hangs over the
global economy especially in the
developing world
even before the conflict developing
countries were struggling to recover
from the pandemic with record inflation
rising interest rates and looming debt
burdens
their ability to respond has been erased
by exponential increases in the cost of
financing
now their bread basket is being bombed
russia and ukraine represent more than
half of the world's supply of sunflower
oil
and about 30 percent of the world's
wheat
ukraine alone
provides more than half of the world's
food programs with supply
food
fuel and fertilizer fertilizer prices
are skyrocketing
supply chains are being disrupted and
the costs and delays of transportation
of imported goods when available
are at record levels
and all of this is eating the poorest
the hardest
and planting the seeds for political
instability and unrest around the globe
grain prices have already exceeded those
at the start of the arab spring
and the food riots of 2007 2008.
the fao's global food prices index is at
the its highest level ever
45 african and least developed countries
import at least one third of their wheat
from ukraine and russia
18 of those countries import at least 50
percent
this includes countries like burkina
faso egypt democratic republic of the
congo lebanon libya somalia sudan and
yemen
we must do everything possible to avert
of hurricane a hurricane of hunger and
the meltdown of the global food system
in addition we are seeing clear evidence
of these war draining resources and
attention from other trouble spots in
desperate need
i renew my appeal for countries to find
creative ways to finance increased
humanitarian and development recovery
needs
worldwide
and to give generously and to
immediately release pledged funds
my plea to leaders
is to resist the temptation of
increasing military budget at the
expense
of official development assistance and
climate action
in a world
in a world developing countries are
getting pummeled
they face a cascade of crisis beyond
ukraine war
we cannot forget covet and the impacts
of climate change in particular drought
against the backdrop of these immense
interconnected challenges i'm announcing
today the establishing of a global
crisis response group on food energy and
finance in the u.n secretariat
i've also asked the dep secretary
general to lead an international
steering committee with partners to
oversee these efforts
and in the coming days we will be
consulting with member states willing to
champion the actions needed to carry
forward the global emergency response
that will be required for this looming
crisis
make no mistake
every day people especially women and
children
will bear the brunt of this unfolding
tragedy
the war also shows how the global
addiction to fossil fuels is placing
energy security climate action and the
entire global economy at the mercy of
geopolitics
finally
further escalation of the war whether by
accident or design
threatens all of humanity
raising the alert of russian nuclear
forces is a bone chilling development
the prospect of nuclear conflict once
unthinkable
is now back within the realm of
possibility
the security and safety of nuclear
facilities must also be preserved
it's time to stop the order unleashed on
the people of ukraine and get on the
path of diplomacy and peace
i've been in close contact with a number
of countries including china france
germany india israel and turkey on
mediation efforts to bring an end to
this war
the appeals for peace must be heard
this tragedy must stop
it's never too late for diplomacy and
dialogue
we need an immediate cessation of
hostilities and serious negotiations
based on the principles of the event
charter and international law
we need peace
peace for the people of ukraine
peace
for the world
we need peace
now
thank
you okay
we have time for a couple of questions
uh
all right uh first question margaret
thank you secretary general uh do you
support ukraine's calls for a no-fly
zone
that is a matter that as you know has
been analyzed by a number of countries
that considered that possibility as a
risk of escalation that could create a
global conflict and it is based on that
analysis that i think we need to be
prudent even if i understand
the
dramatic appeal of the ukrainian
government
uh thank you very much mr secretary
general uh donetsk authorities reported
today that the
ukrainian side hitted the heart of the
city of donetsk by missile tochka ooh
and the warhead of this missile was
filled by the cluster munitions i was
following the security council but i
haven't heard anything about this is the
u.n aware of this incident
i've seen the news about this incident
and i have to say that our position is
very clear
any
attack
on civilians or civilian infrastructure
is regrettable if
accidental
and condemnable
if done on purpose
but let's be clear the overwhelming
majority of civilian casualties and the
overwhelming majority of civilian
infrastructure destructed
was done
in the context of the war by the russian
forces
thank you secretary general it's pamela
falk from cbs news
you talk about
mediation but the talks have adjourned
for the day
is there anything you have done or will
do and have you reached out to russia's
president putin thank you yes we are
doing our best
i've talked with a number of leaders
that are in permanent contact with the
president putin and of course we
consider that is absolutely essential
for
an effort an additional effort to make
the russian federation understand that
this war is becoming an absolute
nightmare and to create the conditions
for
the
war to be stopped and for serious
negotiations to be put in place
thank you very much
thank you very much
shared
[Music]
springboard for achieving
security
and for offering its members a space
coexistence which
is naturally means
is
tackling this substance
mutual benefits until
in the south
security threats resulting from an
increase in terrorism foreign
is
focusing on the osce's mandate
my country has no experience and has
never taken part in an armed
conflict for this reason that my country
has already
upon each member of the international
community
we encourage cooperation between the usc
and the united nations and express our
support to the president
in his efforts
[Music]
of china
of
foreign
at this meeting i have listened
carefully to the briefings by
mr rowe and usg
china has always supported the efforts
by the un and the security council on
the basis of chapter 8 of the u.n
charter to develop partnership with
regional organizations including osce
with a view to effectively addressing
challenges in international peace and
security osce covers a large area and is
fairly rich in its coordination
mechanisms for years it has done a lot
of work in enhancing the mutual trust
among member states preventing and
resolving conflicts and addressing
non-traditional security threats
we welcome and are pleased to see the
role of osce in complementing the
international system with the un ellis
corps
mr president
the international situation is
undergoing deep challenges and is full
of instability and uncertainty
the outbreak of the crisis in ukraine
has further led us to think how to
maintain peace and stability
in international architecture
and focus more on the genuine avenue
towards universal security and common
development
we must see
new enlightenments and answers from the
history of and the current severe
challenges facing osce
first
adhere to the general direction of
dialogue and cooperation
even in the most intensive moment of the
cold
the more frictions differences and
potential risks there are
the more important and necessary it is
to enhance understanding and mutual
trust the world is now in a new era the
path of dialogue and cooperation should
become wider and wider rather than
narrower and narrower
differences among states international
interests social system and ideology
shall not become an obstacle to dialogue
let alone a reason for confrontation
yeah second
of indivisible security was first
established
this principle carries special carries
special significance under the current
circumstances therefore it should not
only be upheld but all the more should
be implemented
the final solution to the crisis in
ukraine is to take seriously and respect
the reasonable security concerns of all
states and form a balanced effective and
sustainable european security
architecture
confrontation should be completely
rejected
sticking to her germany mortality and
provoking block confrontation will only
bring the world disasters
and exacerbate turmoil and division
that is the case in europe
it is also the case in other regions
this world
does not need a new cold war
this world can live with common growth
and progress
under the banner of multilateralism
strengthen unity and cooperation and
work together for a community of shared
future for mankind
mr president
china's position on the question of
ukraine
is consistent and clear
recently president xi jinping held a
video conference with leaders of france
and germany
where he pointed out that sovereignty
and territory integrity of all states
shall be respected that the purposes and
principles of the u.n charter shall be
observed that the reasonable security
concerns of all states shall be taken
seriously
and that all efforts towards peaceful
settlement of crises
shall be supported
the four points
represent the
most authoritative position of china on
the question of ukraine
based on this position china will
strengthen communication and
coordination with all the parties
concerned and
play a constructive role in promoting
peace through negotiations
china is
deeply concerned about and regrets the
developments in ukraine a recession of
hostilities is a common aspiration of
the international community
dialogue and
negotiations the only feasible and
realistic
recently
russia and ukraine
have held multiple rounds of
negotiations and have demonstrated
aspiration and willingness to would you
further continue negotiations
the international community must help
sustain the positive momentum
actively
and actively
encourage
and support russian ukraine negotiations
and create the necessary conditions and
environment to that end
the crisis in ukraine is interwoven with
european security and stability we
encourage osce to bring into full play
its advantages and set up the necessary
platform for the negotiation and
communication of the party's concern
we call for maximum restraint
we call for effective guarantee for
civilian
security and their basic needs and we
call for safe and unimpeded humanitarian
corridor so as to prevent
that
appearance of a
humanitarian crisis of a larger scale
china's six-point initiative on the
humanitarian situation in ukraine
has more and more support from other
countries we have also provided
humanitarian assistance to ukraine in
kind
we support the united nations in food
playing its coordinating role in
humanitarian assistance to ukraine and
we are ready to work with other parties
in achieving consensus on the council's
response to the humanitarian crisis in
ukraine
we must also note that
three foot deep ice doesn't come from
when this coast
the current status
in the situation
in ukraine is an outcome of the
interaction of conflicts historical
presence
to solve
calm and rational thinking
all the more needed wanting use of
sanctions will not only not help solve
the issue but will create new problems
escalating sanctions has already
affected and will continue to affect
global finance energy food
transportation supply chain and
other areas devastating the already
fragile world economy caused by the
pandemic
seriously and adversely affecting
people's livelihoods developing
countries in particular
we once again called for
greater diplomatic efforts by the
international community to de-escalate
tensions
and bring the ukrainian issue back to
the political check
thank you very much mr president and i'd
like to thank under secretary general de
carlo also for her
briefing this morning and minister rao
i'd like to wish you a very warm welcome
to the council and many thanks for your
informative briefing earlier
at the outset i'd certainly like to
express aaron's admiration and
appreciation to the government and
people of poland
for your generosity and solidarity to
those fleeing the war in ukraine
we in ireland are also fully committed
to supporting the humanitarian
response mr president the helsinki final
act signed in 1975
laid the foundation for what is now the
osce
as an inclusive forum where east and
west could meet
the osce with its unique concept of
comprehensive security has served the
european continent well
for almost 50 years
as a founding member of the osce ireland
regards the organization as a vital
instrument for european stability and
security we greatly value the osce's
work on conflict prevention resolution
its activities on human rights and its
regional role under the un charter
as we now experience another tragic
episode in europe's long and often
violent history
the work of the osce takes on a renewed
significance
the russian federation's relentless
unprovoked and unjustified attack on
ukraine
casts a dark shadow across our continent
as innocent civilians in ukraine suffer
and we watch a humanitarian catastrophe
unfold
ireland once again
strongly condemns the russian
federation's invasion of ukraine
a sovereign and an independent
country
and called on it to uphold its
international obligations
the russian federation must immediately
cease hostilities unconditionally
withdraw its troops from the entire
territory of ukraine and refrain from
using further threats or the use of
force of any kind against ukraine
or any other osce participating state
we urge it to turn away from war and
choose the path of dialogue and
diplomacy
not bullets and bombs
mr president ireland welcomes the
priorities for 2022 outlined by the
chairperson in office of the osce
i want to assure minister rao of
ireland's full support in his important
role
as under secretary general de carlo said
earlier the osce is a unique
organization extending from vancouver to
vladivostok
it is the embodiment of a vision for
europe's security architecture a vision
of creating a different relationship
for resolving issues between states
its strength lies in its value as an
essential forum for free and open
engagement this is why we welcome in
particular the renewed european security
dialogue initiated by the chairperson in
office aimed at using the full potential
of the osce as a platform for dialogue
since 2014
the special monitoring mission in
ukraine has made a significant
difference to the lives of people living
along the contact line in eastern
ukraine
away from public limelight
the mission negotiated local ceasefires
enabling repair works and critical
civilian
infrastructure giving millions in
eastern ukraine access to fundamental
services
it was an indispensable impartial voice
and the eyes and ears of participating
states on the ground
allow me to express our sincere
condolences on the death of marina
fanina
the smm national member killed by
shelling
we commend the osce for its evacuation
of staff and we recognize the evacuation
as a temporary measure and acknowledge
that the mission is working differently
right now and is ready to resume its
monitoring work
we stress the importance of an osce
presence on the ground into the future
mr president while the eyes of the world
are rightly focused on ukraine we are
mindful that the institutions and field
offices of the osce continue to operate
throughout the region indeed it's vital
that they do so
ireland continues to support renewed
efforts towards a negotiated
comprehensive and sustainable settlement
of the conflict between armenia and
azerbaijan
particularly on the long-term status of
nagorno-karabakh
we believe the osce minsk group is the
appropriate format through which to
achieve this objective
is essential that both sides
meaningfully engage in this effort
ireland together with our eu partners
stands ready to contribute to the
intensification of negotiations in this
format
ireland strongly supports the polish
chairs intention to keep conflict
prevention and resolution at the top of
the osce's agenda including in georgia
and moldova
here too will the osce's work to advance
the women peace and security agenda be
critical particularly for those women
who have been forced to flee ukraine
we also welcome poland's emphasis on
responding to new and emerging threats
to regional peace and security such as
violent extremism
and attacks in cyberspace as well as the
challenges we may face in a post-covet
environment through effective
multilateralism
ireland recalls that the osce plays a
unique role in holding all states all
participating states
accountable to osce principles and
commitments
the inclusion of civil society is
essential in this regard we fully
support the osce's work on democracy and
human rights and reaffirm our steadfast
support for the invaluable role played
by the osce autonomous institutions in
particular the office of democratic
institutions and human rights whose work
on election monitoring we support
without reservation
in conclusion mr president
the osce's comprehensive approach to
security is as pertinent and relevant as
ever
respect for human rights the rule of law
and economic and environmental progress
are all essential elements for
sustaining peace and prosperity
we look forward to working closely with
the chairperson in office to ensure
strong complementary partnership between
the un and the osce
thank you president
of ireland
thank you mr president
at the outset let me begin by welcoming
his excellency professor rob
minister of foreign office of poland
i also thank him for his briefing on the
activities of the osce
and its priorities in its capacity as
the osce a person in office
i also thank usg rosemary de carlo for
our briefing
the role of regional and sub-regional
organizations in maintenance of
international peace and security as well
as their cooperation with the united
nations is provided in chapter 8
of the u.n charter
we support active engagement between the
un and ose based on the framework for
cooperation and coordination
signed in 1993.
regional organizations have a critical
role to play in addressing challenges to
security environment
by promoting dialogue between the
parties and distributing external
influence
we are of the view that bilateral and
regional agreements negotiated between
the parties provide a good basis for
lasting and peaceful resolution of
disputes
the osce has attributes that make it the
forum of choice in many situations
first and foremost importance the osce
is an inclusive euro atlantic forum for
consultation and joint action
osc is a structured dialogue mechanism
anchored in the guiding principles of
transparency
collective ownership inclusiveness and
respect for diverging views is aimed at
rebuilding trust in multilateralism amid
renewed geopolitical rivalry in the osce
area
the challenges converting confronting
the osce community come from different
sources
they include not only challenges to
sovereignty but threats to peace from
ethnic tensions and violent separatism
within states
the osce as the world's largest security
organization is also addressing some of
the toughest transnational threats such
as proliferation of weapons terrorism
cyber security migration environmental
damage and drug trafficking
while noting the ongoing global
counterterrorism efforts and
contribution of ose we would like to
take this opportunity to reiterate the
importance of this issue osce was among
the first regional organizations to
strongly condemn the terrorist attack on
indian parliament in 2001.
osce needs to take into account such
cross-border terrorist attacks and other
new and emerging threats
in this context the eight point action
plan on counterterrorism proposed by
india's external affairs minister
on 11th january 2021 while addressing
the council also merits serious
consideration of the osce
osce has been playing an important role
in facilitating implementation of
package of measures across both sides of
contract line in eastern ukraine however
recent developments in ukraine and
consequent deterioration of security
situation have altered the functioning
of the special monitoring mission
india has been consistent in calling for
an immediate end to all hostilities in
ukraine our prime minister has
repeatedly called for an urgent
ceasefire and that there is no other
path left but to but of dialogue and
diplomacy
the human toll continues to mount and
the humanitarian situation has become
dire
india undertook
intensive and immediate steps to
evacuate its nationals till date about
22 500 indians have returned home safely
we are grateful to all our partners for
their support in our evacuation efforts
we call for direct contacts and
negotiations with a view to seize
hostilities
india has been in touch with both the
russian federation and ukraine in this
regard and will continue to remain
engaged we continue to undermine the
need to respect the u.n charter
international law and the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of states
we also support oace minx group's
continued efforts for a peaceful
resolution of the conflict between
armenia and azerbaijan
india believes that any lasting
resolution of the conflict can only be
achieved peacefully through diplomatic
negotiations
and we call on parties to implement the
agreement reached we note with concern
that steps that have been committed have
yet to materialize
to conclude mr president we recognize
the significant contribution of oace to
the promotion of a rules based
international order and strengthening
multilateralism
we join all other members of the council
to extend our good wishes to poland's
chairmanship of osce
i also take this opportunity to
sincerely thank foreign minister of
poland for the generosity and help
extend it to our citizens in their safe
return to from conflict zones in ukraine
i thank you mr president
is by listening to the statement of the
chairperson office of the usc
what he would talk about even before he
took the floor
we are surprised
and this is not the first time
went way beyond the remit of
impartiality we're surprised by her
statement
stipulated uh under her obligations as
an international civil servant
and uh
information
raises doubts as to who's sitting around
this table
senior official secretary
or a representative of one of the member
states
drawn attention to the topic of
mediation in conflict
what type of mediation can we talk about
by the ukrainian armed forces
it was filled uh with cluster bombs and
that struck the heart of donetsk
so the representatives of western
countries didn't manage to mention this
either who for eight
is
the actions of the ukrainian armed
forces and the nationalists in donbass
13 000 people have died you mentioned
that figure they died in combat
concerns russia as well
who are most of these unfortunate people
most of these
apparently from a russian
shot
regret any
people who die in a conflict
i just like to make two clarifying
points
that was something that the new york
times itself stated
on the internet there's information
circulating
his actions was not actually journalist
activity it was uh filmmaking and that's
uh on open access that information
is
controlled by the ukrainian armed forces
and the ukrainian uh
it was them who opened fire on their
vehicles
we were under no illusion we knew that
today's meeting would in no way be on
cooperation between the un and the osce
the demand for cooperation over recent
years
decreased due to it
by a certain cover statement to replace
the united charter by a rules-based
order
to the east of vienna
unacceptable tones
on the 15th of february
we had substantive talks with him
don't go anywhere he talked about the
importance of the proactive
physical solutions and
agenda and achieve compromises
embracing the role of an honest broker
however today we can note that the
polish chairmanship of the oasis
has almost failed
only in the middle of march though
positions
in the osce
the implementation of the principle
and we did not uh contact them regarding
these matters
is
and the indivisibility of that very
security
principle requires avoiding any actions
in 1994
is
unambiguously confirmed
requiring unilateral sanctions
unilateral agreements rather for itself
oh guarantee is rather
the situation foreign ukraine well
against
here as well
representatives
forces
[Music]
[Music]
agreements
at the same time
is
violations were required
destruction by the kiev
wave of refugees
objective
[Music]
by russia
from the security council something we
view as a deliberate publication
humans
and then
ammunitions
civilians
falling
pipeline systems
um
foreign
is
actually takes place don't say we didn't
warn you
mr president
i would like to urge the chairperson in
the office to prevent the destruction of
the overseas
but within it a number of other topics
are
is
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity at the representative of the
united arab emirates
at the outset
i would like to decided
for foreign affairs of poland and
chairman in office of the organization
for security and cooperation in europe
for 2022. and under secretary general
for political and peace building affairs
for their comprehensive briefings
of these organizations
to see the united nations strengthening
its relations with various regional
organizations including the organization
for security and cooperation in europe
the organization has a long history of
working to resolve conflict and ease
from the expertise and mediation efforts
of the organization to find a solution
to the conflict in your country
the role of this organization is also
important considering the continued
deterioration of the security
the wider region especially as
ukrainians search for safety away from
conflict resulting in a growing number
of refugees that now exceeds 2.5 million
the organization's role in dealing with
the repercussions of this conflict is
important
at the regional level
ukraine is one of the five largest
largest exporters of wheat in the world
and an important source of wheat for the
world food program
this
situation will particularly affect
developing countries that depend on
wheat imports
and increase in its global warming
in addition to the crisis in ukraine
participating
have several security and political
concerns including frozen conflicts in
georgia and moldova
tensions in the balkan peninsula
as well as the officers
including the emphasis on compliance
with the fundamental principles
of peaceful relations among states
the important role played by the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe as an umbrella
institution for various views and
concerns across the region
my country therefore looks forward to
the continued cooperation between the
united nations and the organization in
the maintenance of regional and
international peace and security
i resume my function as president of the
council
to respond to the comments being
expressed at the meeting
mr president
madam under secretary general
distinguished ambassadors
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for this useful and timely
debate and for allowing me to
participate
i appreciate the
interest from the members
of the security council
also
i recognize the presence of ambassadors
and high-ranking representatives of
countries from outside the security
council some of them sitting today in
the audience and some of them submitting
written statements
for the record
it is
fair to say that the international
community is currently at a critical
juncture
even before the current crisis
we saw the erosion of a practical
implementation of helsinki principles
and commitments
today we should pay special attention to
how fundamental un and oec principles
are implemented
and how to
react when those principles are violated
in carrying out my task as the oec
chairman in office i will be
tirelessly calling on all participating
states to abide
by our joint
commitments
i would like to
reassure partners
that i will not shower shy away from
facilitating dialogue and seeking ways
to advance settlement
of the ongoing regional
and
frozen conflicts
as i
indicated before
this will exactly be the focus of my
upcoming trips to moldova
and this south carcasses
later during the year
i will visit the western balkans
and
central asia
the ongoing non-compliance by a oec
participating state
may complicate this effort
however
i will do my best to attentively listen
to all partners
to
promote our joint principles
and
commitments we will continue to show
unwavering support for the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of georgia
within its internationally
recognized borders
we are determined to keep the conflict
around abkhazia
and south ossetia
high on the osce agenda as well as seek
possibilities to support the
communities affected by the conflict
i will make even greater efforts
to increase the involvement of the oce
women's group and its cultures in
resolving the dispute between
azerbaijan and armenia
we encourage armenia and azerbaijan
to engage in dialogue aimed and at
contributing to security stability and
prosperity
in the region
in conclusion
let me reintegrate that
only by
reverting to un and oec
e-principles
we will be able to
ease tensions
and prevent
military conflicts in the future thank
you
excellent see mr rao for
statements
i give the floor to the representative
of ukraine
thank you mr president
oeca chairman in office
madame under secretary
general distinguished colleagues
and we have no doubt who sits
in the soviet seat behind the nameplate
russian federation
the general assembly gave a clear answer
to this question
it is the aggressive state
not a shred of doubt
i would like to start with expressing my
gratitude to the oecd chairman
in office for his briefing and in
particular for his clear qualification
of the russian actions against ukraine
hasan provoked an unjustified aggression
which runs both
counter-boost the yuan charter and the
helsinki final act
all oec commitments and principles
minister rao
welcome to our regular intervention
meetings
where members of the un family
gather around the aggressive state
who is in denial
and
makes no effort to struggle with its
addiction
to killing
innocent citizens
indeed both the uan and the oec are now
at the critical juncture with all their
fundamental principles being violated
flagrantly openly
and deliberately
violated by russia that has pretended to
be a key stakeholder in maintaining
international peace and security
instead it has been a main provider of
insecurity
and circa encircling itself with a belt
of conflicts
on the 24th of february russia went even
further launching an aggressive war
against ukraine
the war that serves an illustration of
what the iran founding members and
russia was not in
in their list a remind tried to save
succeeding generations from
i therefore commend the chairman
in office for his strong commitment to
pursue as his main priority
determination of the war
on the basis of respect to the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
we fully support human oriented approach
of poland's oec chairmanship with a
special focus on protection of the
civilian population affected by
conflicts
russian troops continue to commit war
crimes and crimes against humanity in
ukraine erasing any difference with
their nazi predecessors 80 years ago
cities and villages destroyed to the
ground mass graves
terror against civilians in the occupied
territories abduction and killing of
representatives of local authorities
activists and journalists
i reiterate my call on the security
council and today address this call to
the oec chair as well
as well to fallacy to facilitate release
of ivan fedorov
mayor of mali topple zaparilla region
who was detained by the russian soldiers
on 11th of march
now he is reportedly tortured due to his
refusal
to collaborate with the aggressor
unfortunately the russian occupants step
up their repressive practices as
yesterday they abducted johann matveyev
mayor of nepro rudner another town in
zappos region
russia proceeds with repressive
practices
as it has completely failed to create an
illusion of public support on the
territories he temporarily occupies
residents of herson bergansk melitopol
and ergodark and other cities and towns
in occupation
have no fear to take to the streets to
say to the occupants
go away we are ukraine
unarmed
staring down the barrel of a russian gun
russian attempts to employ in her son
its usual practice of proclaiming
a fake people's republic was immediately
rejected by the hirson regional council
that adopted his at its emergency
session on the 12th of march a statement
that her son region has been and will be
ukraine
the mayor of her son solidarized with
this statement
there is no place in ukraine where the
russian troops are welcome
they feel it quite well and they have
stopped restraining themselves
mariupol remains the most powerful
example
the toll of civilian casualties
following russian bombardments and
shellings reached almost 2200 innocent
local residents
if you want to visualize it just think
of at least 11 generally assembly holes
so many citizens were killed
in mariupol
early on sunday morning russian rockets
stroke the averif international
peacekeeping and security center
35 people were killed and 134 wounded
russian ministry of defense tried to
whitewash this crime by claiming it
aimed deferring
mercenaries
this is not true as only ukrainian
citizens were affected
countering russian aggression
must be a centerpiece of the oec efforts
to restore security
in the european continent
we consider that the oec has to
contribute to the implementation of the
resolution es
11 1
aggression against ukraine adopted by
the overwhelming majority on the 2nd of
march
we welcome the invocation of the moscow
mechanism
which is
important to register all war crimes and
crimes against humanity committed by the
russian federation in its war against
ukraine
we also underline the need to explore
all oec tools to document russian crimes
and ensure a public and timely reaction
by the chair and person in office
special representatives and the oec
autonomous institutions
we expect the odr to be vocal on the on
the cases of flagrant human rights
violations stemming from the russian
aggression against ukraine
russia is intensifying its propaganda
and disinformation campaign and we
consider that the oec representative on
freedom of the media has to pay close
attention to russia's false narratives
we appreciate her strong stance against
violations against journalists which
remains an element of the russian
aggression
we note her condemnation of healing of
bran renault a u.s filmmaker and
journalist in european on the 13th of
march
i quote
he is another casualty of the horrible
ongoing russian invasion in ukraine and
his death is a blow to media freedom end
of quote
i also express our profound condolences
to the relatives of miss maria fenina of
smm who was killed by the aggressor
strong and clear positioned by the high
commissioner for national minorities and
dire conditions
of national minorities in ukraine
stemming from the russian invasion
remains a long overdue
he also has to be proactive on rebutting
russia's propaganda fakes
we also look forward to extending the
oec smm mandate for another year
it would be powerful message of the oec
engagement with ukraine
i would like to to thank at this point
the under secretary general rose marie
de carlo for her very principled
position
for her being a very strong member of
the secretary general's team
and on this occasion i would like to
quote the secretary general statement
that he made less than an hour ago and i
quote ukraine is on fire
the country is being commit this
decimated before the eyes of the world
the impact on civilians is reaching
terrifying proportions
countless
innocent people including women and
children have been killed
after being hit by russian forces roads
airports
and schools lie in ruins
according to the who at least
24
health facilities
have
been destroyed hundreds of thousands of
people are without water or electricity
with each passing hour
two things are increasingly clear
first it keeps getting worse
second
whatever the outcome this law will have
no winners only losers
then the secretary general also wisely
said
yet there is another dimension
of this conflict that gets
obscured
this war goes far beyond ukraine
it is also an assault on the world's
most vulnerable people
and countries
while war
reigns over ukraine a sword of democracy
hangs over the global economy especially
the developing world
even before the conflict
developing countries were struggling to
recover from the pandemic
with record inflation
rising interest rates
and looming debt burdens
the ability to respond has been erased
by exponential increases in the cost of
financing
now their bread basket
that's ukraine
is being bombed
end of quote
dear colleagues
what is happening now is not only about
ukraine's survival
unlike putin and his henchmen
ukraine will survive the russian
invasion
it's about survival of both the un and
the oec
and it is about deputianization of
russia
and his gradual returning to the tenants
of international law in the post-putin
era
the putin's regime
nears its end
at the same time it has inflicted such a
heavy damage on the russian society that
it would take decades to bring russia
back to to at least the level of
democracy it achieved in the 90s of the
past century
in fact moscow required 15 years to
cover distance between formal signing of
the helsinki final act
and conscious choice to be a part of
building a new europe as envisaged in
the 1990 paris charter
eventually
moscow failed
and yet we deem that now the oec
should play a special role
in getting ready to support post-putin
russia
on his future pass back
to the family of democratic nations
on the new leadership
with new ambassadors
and new representatives
it's not an easy task
but we will not be able to break the
vicious circle
of violence without restoring respect by
russia of the fundamental principles
enshrined in the helsinki final act
i therefore
call upon the oecd chair and the oec
autonomous institutions to start
considering
the modalities of work we suppose put in
russia
as there will be no automatic return to
normalcy
neither here
in new york nor in the osce and i thank
you
[Music]
the meeting is adjourned
um
[Music]
thank you
who's in charge
okay
from the floor okay
do
yes
is
videos
okay
ladies and gentlemen
i'm pleased to have briefed the united
nations security council
in my capacity of a
chairman in office of the organization
for security and cooperation
in europe
both the united nations and the oece
work to maintain international peace and
security
and safeguard the
respect for international law
including the basic human rights and
fundamental
freedoms
this is
why they both
condemned in the strongest terms
the
military aggression of russia on ukraine
in discriminate attacks against
civilians
sharing hospitals and schools
is not only inhuman
it is nothing but a crime under
international law
we always see police chairmanship is now
facing a completely
different reality than a month ago
the war in ukraine has dominated
its agenda
almost completely
russian aggression shakes the very
foundation of the oec
we see russia defy its primary
responsibility to act
as a guardian of international peace and
security
both
as a member of oec as well as
the permanent member of the united
nations security council
instead it
chooses to act
as an aggressor
this long planned military attack
with the participation of another state
belarus
is unprovoked
unjustified
and
illegal
such a flagrant breach of oec principles
and commitments
poses questions about stability of a
rules-based
order
still
we believe oec is able to keep these
states talking
in good times
and bad
poland is convinced
it is
in the best interest of the organization
and its participating states
to work
on proper modus operandi
to fulfill
oec
mandate
right now
the primary focus of oec work in ukraine
will be to help a very humanitarian
crisis
and create the conditions
for assistance
and evacuation
overseas stands
ready to continue its cooperation with
the united nations
we have established close coordination
with the
u.n office for the coordination of
humanitarian affairs
and the u.n high commissioner for
refugees
international organization for
immigration and the international
committee
of a red cross
the obc
[Music]
wealth welcomes any genuine effort
that contributes to stopping the ongoing
hostilities
and can lead to finding a sustainable
peaceful
solution
with that said
talk must be accompanied by actions
i reintegrate with join call i made with
osce secretary general
helga smith on the
very first day of irrational aggression
for the immediate secession of all
military
activities
we call on russia
to stop the deplorable acts
we call on russia
to stop selling civilians where attempts
of evacuation
we call on russia to stop shelling and
dropping bombs
on homes hospitals
and streets full of innocent people
most of whom
are children
and women
we call on russia to honor its
international obligations and
commitments
any sustainable
political solution must fully respect
sovereignty territorial integrity
and
independence of ukraine within its
international
recognized borders finally
we call on russia to engage in a
meaningful
and substantial dialogue
to seek a peaceful solution
to the current crisis
the dole to diplomacy
is still
open
thank you
thank you yes thank you very much
minister rowitz pamela faulk from cbs
news
you have accommodated so many refugees
at what point is that a problem for
poland how many can you take in and what
do you need to do that thank you
i must say that we
used to host
1.5 million people
before this crisis so
the ukrainians
who visited us and who decided to stay
with us
were
living working studying and learning in
poland
since the beginning
of aggression
we have received
1.6
million
ukrainians
the overwhelming majority of them
are
in touch with a
friends
and relatives
who already live in poland
but
the
polish government
is
assisting
the
help spontaneous
support of public society
that is being extended to them so we
have just
adopted the bill of law
that
gives all the
privileges
that we the polish citizens enjoy in
respect of healthcare
[Music]
opportunities to
learn and study in public schools and
polish universities
also
pay
access to labor market
and also the
opportunity to take part in our economic
life for example by launching
their own businesses in poland so
all that indicates that
we are ready to
host the considerable number
of our
ukrainian men
neighbors who are in need but certainly
no country can do anything like that on
its own
so it's let me just tell you that
when europe went through the immigration
crisis in
2015 the continent as a whole
received less than 1 million
immigrants
now in poland
alone
we have already 1.6
million refugees of war
and think about
other neighboring countries
which
accepted
a smaller portion but still a very
considerable
obvious influx
so
it's
more than obvious
that as i said there is no country in
the world that can handle this kind of
humanitarian crisis
on its own
hello mr minister i'm margaret beshear
with the voice of america
in your national capacity i'd like to
ask you uh the united states has
expressed objections uh to poland
transferring its mig jets to ukraine
ukraine is still asking for them
have you been in touch with your
ukrainian counterpart to try and find a
workaround to still deliver these jets
is this still a possibility
i'm in touch with
our
american counterparts with our nato
and european union
counterparts and of course with the
ukrainian ones
as far as your question is concerned i
can only say that this kind of this kind
of decision
has to be made
by the nato alliance as a whole
but not a
one member state
because the
impact of this kind of decision
is going to affect
the alliance
as a whole so there is no one single
nato member who could make this decision
for the rest of the alliance thank you
thank you
thank you very much
thank you ladies and gentlemen